now speaking of protecting the youth
when parent michelle brown discovered a
sexually graphic book was being made
available to students she confronted the
local school board and its response
ended up proving her point
here's an excerpt and i'm going to
really try to be careful so i'll get
kicked out
excited now he pushed into her as she
squeezed her eyes and tightly as she
could her tongue circled her lips he
pushed harder his breath heavy and
labored she scratched his back and he
cried out she bit his ear and pulled his
hair there's a lot more to it it's fifty
shades of gray and ccsd excuse me yes we
have children at home i know
streaming and
it's really not don't you find the irony
in that
you're exactly saying exactly what i'm
telling you
[Music]
joining us now is that brave mother
michelle brown uh shel i'm
guessing they didn't see the irony
no
no and and the irony is even more so is
that i'm in cherokee county georgia and
we are one of the top republican
counties in the state
and let me start by saying i love my
county i love where i live i love being
in a conservative town i love my schools
the school system
but
over the last couple years i've noticed
especially since covet hit we had a
little bit of a short time of digital
learning
slowly but surely it started becoming
awakened to see some of the things that
were in the curriculum
um and so i noticed last summer that
there were lots of news stories and
parents coming up and talking about uh
books and it was becoming alarming and i
thought well thank goodness i live in
conservative cherokee county and then
come this fall
at the board meeting i saw a parent get
up and speak about one of the books and
then the next school board meeting son
another parent get up and speak about
one of the books
and so in a statement of fox the
the spokesperson for the school district
said that you don't have uh st you did
not have students at the high school
level within the school district
and had been repeatedly advised
that you could file a challenge to
remove the book
but you have not done so so yeah you
don't have a high school student
uh and you could have filed a challenge
you didn't
well we did um however so i am uh
speaking on behalf of our group our
group is variety of um we're small group
we're underground if you will grassroots
and we have about 10 to 12 of us and
their parents grandparents they have
elementary middle school high school
students within ccsd
we initially started because we wanted
to help uh with no left turn in
education to uh remove or close the
loophole in
sb226 which was the safe school library
bill um in other words it
if i gave you or excuse me if i gave a
child one of these books i would go to
jail
but they can get it in our school
libraries and it's not okay shel the
left is like you're a book manor you're
like the old puritans you just want to
ban books so you're a book banner and
they think you're a troublemaker and
we like the fact that you raised this
issue
that's exactly what the the school chair
board called it she just put out an uh
article today calling it the banned book
last list and that's exactly what
liberals say so i'm kind of questioning
shouldn't we have an approved list
shouldn't we have books that are deemed
appropriate to be in the schools in the
first place all right so we appreciate
it thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else